humans are humans getting complimented
getting roses feels nice no matter how
many [ __ ] roses you have it's still
nice it really does it's really just
nice yeah [ __ ]
[Music]
the garyvee audio experience
vaynernation what is good super excited
about this episode very uh family
episode vaynersports talk i have three
phenomenal young men with me we're going
to chop up about a lot of things we're
going to talk a lot of sports we'll
probably talk a little bit nfts uh we'll
we'll talk about debating i mean when
brandon parker and i are together we're
going to argue about something that's
just it's in the aj shaking his head in
the background like that's just a
guarantee probably you know but we're
still gonna have to probably play
one-on-one and film it i actually
believed through your conviction after
debating with you in alabama a couple
weeks ago that you would probably win
but i i have a deep feeling that i could
still pull out an upset uh and so we'll
talk about that we'll talk about this
upcoming draft i don't want aj to get
mad at me but there's a young man
sitting here that if the jets leadership
is listening to i'm desperate for them
to draft them i'm not sure if that's
legal or not illegal or what i'm doing
here but like and alan super excited for
you so why don't you guys introduce
yourself we'll go around the circle
brandon why don't you say hello real
quick yo yup my name is brandon parker
i'm the ceo of vayner football and just
here happy to be here with both a rob
you and dbell looking forward to
chopping it up
d-bell uh what's up my name is david
bell i'm currently in the process to get
drafted at end of this month and just
really excited to see where i end up at
love it allen yo what's good is allen
robinson went to penn state drafted by
jacksonville they've been in chicago and
now with the rams you know which i'm
super excited about
love it so a lot to talk about uh
brandon obviously you rep these two
young men let's so we'll start with you
at the top of the triangle um what's on
your mind what are you excited about
both of these guys are going through
major major exciting transitions yeah
david you know starting his journey
having a crazy year at purdue which i'm
sure made you happy um and now going
into league and now and alan
going to the super bowl champs
like a formidable super team like that's
a big thing so when you're on the other
side repping
individuals in different parts of their
career
what's a consistent
what's uh what's the thing you focus on
how do you how do you help there's a lot
of people who are listening right now
all of which probably spam aj 24 7.
nobody gets hit up more than aj
from uh
because so many people want to be sports
agents and so i see i get hit up a ton
of like hey i hit up aj can i work at
vaynersports like it's such a thing that
so many of the listeners want to do in
their life because a lot of us grow up
wanting to play like these two and
somewhere along the way we realize we
can't and so for a lot of us it's like
wait a minute i want to rep them what
you know you've been in the i mean you
grew up in this business your dad's a
legend you grew up in it i've got the
privilege of working with you a little
bit further deeper into sports
representation life
how do you think about giving advice
helping alan just went through a big
free agency contract you know
david's going to go to that part of like
you know even from a business standpoint
knowing how many people that are
listening you know people think like
you're going to be an nfl player and
then you start looking at taxes and
expenses and i'm sure david's probably
already even gone through crossing some
of these teas and eyes in his mind it's
it's not your trillionaire and your
rookie contract
what are you what are you telling these
young men
well i think uh first and foremost you
know it's different strokes for
different folks to be honest
um these two guys have a lot of similar
traits to one another which is obviously
what attracted us to david because we
were able to see kind of a rob's
progression being in the league for
eight years um even similar to how we
for actually when it came to david you
were the first person to actually tell
me about it say that a little bit louder
for all the people in the back g was the
first person to put me on d bail um and
then when i cut d bell's tape on
which was his freshman and sophomore
year right away i actually had
a very similar feeling is the first time
i saw alan play
um talk about that real quick because
we've got a little time here in the
podcast i want to get people under the
hood
when you say the tape like tell
everybody the work that goes into it
like how many minutes hours how do you
get to the tape like how do you i hit
you up like hey there's this purdue
receiver i think has really got it
how do you go about actually doing the
homework what are you looking for what
were you talking about what do you do
well i mean i'm not a scout so typic so
typically i don't watch a whole lot of
tape unless either someone tells me
about a player or if i just so happen to
see a player that i like then i'll dive
deeper meaning on a saturday you're
walking by the tv watch five minutes
you're like who's this d tackle exactly
you make a mental note and then that
following week that's what happened with
him it's actually
literally walking through my kitchen
three weekends in a row and i was just
watching like some highlights and i saw
number eight three times in a row i'm
patting three weeks ago we're just going
crazy and so and very good-looking
but um it just you know obviously we
have contacts throughout the league that
can get us the tape of course um and
then you know when you've seen it
because like you said before i was
fortunate enough to grow up in the world
where i got to see a lot of great
players yes and they have similar traits
right
um great players just have similar
traits across the board not just on in
football but just as human beings
and you kind of get to know some of
these guys um allen is a great example
and so is d bell very uh personable
relaxed comfortable in their own skin
kind of guys and then once you kind of
see it on the field
um i've just learned over over the years
to just don't over complicate it right
you see a guy that's because
your dad eugene is truly truly one of
the greatest icons of the profession
you feel like there's almost like a
sixth sense yeah like a mix between
intuition and a little bit of math i
really do yeah i really do yeah um
and the traits just
like i said they
they're on the field and they're off the
field traits but especially when it
comes to receivers at this point you can
just kind of tell um the guys that have
just a real high athletic intelligence
what i call it like
being able to just time when the ball
when to go up and pluck the ball out the
air
um knowing what to do after the catch
right you don't have to be necessarily
the fastest or most explosive guy but if
mentally you can be two or three steps
ahead of the other guys it gives you a
chance to really separate yourself as a
player which i think david does really
well
but um it's just funny that all the
things that were similar about these two
guys and um they've they've since built
a really good relationship as well um
you know d bill we both went to purdue
so we got a little a little bit of a
rivalry with a rob when it comes to that
but a rob's shaking his head
doesn't feel like there's really that
much of a rivalry well he'll get his
chain he'll get his chance to speak on
that but to answer your original
question when it comes to advice you
know you as an agent you learn to if it
ain't broke don't break it kind of thing
um so i keep it pretty simple with these
guys because they're
they're both far and above are far away
uh from their peers as it comes to
understanding and maturity right like
neither one of these guys are the kind
of guys that just want to be caught up
and told how good they are
no no not at all not emotionally to what
you were saying and definitely not like
keep them out of trouble right and so
that allows you do you think it's a big
mistake that agents make
um yeah but i don't know i like i think
you have i think you're yeah of course
they're they're in the business they
don't understand they just don't
understand most of them but i think i
think you're very thoughtful about this
like i even and i'm really thoughtful
about it and i think you're even like
i'm really scared because i don't want
to rep someone that's going to drag my
reputation down but i i mean you are
very thoughtful when i when we talk
about a lot of stuff you like you're i
would say cautious like i feel like
you're really like am i going to be
about this k it's almost like you're
pretty binary am i going to be about
this kid and if i'm not and if it
doesn't fit into this feeling i have i'm
just not interested even if they're
gonna be the number one pick in the
draft i think is that true yeah and why
do you think that is
i think i've just seen a lot i've seen
so many great play players like end up
being headaches for agents yeah and end
up it's just not working that and i know
myself
so because i know who i am and like how
i work and
when i meet someone it's just like
meeting somebody you're gonna know
whether or not you're gonna get along
with them well um that's self-awareness
of yourself knowing that you're not
going to be about that anyway so it's
not going to work anyway so you're going
to lose them anyway that's exactly right
that's right exactly right
dave let's talk about self-awareness for
a minute
like you know
you're in a re you know you're now as
somebody who's really going to get
drafted in the nfl like obviously at
purdue that's a real program you've been
reading things about yourself on the
internet you're a human being
you know right like but this is probably
the most stuff you've read about
yourself
right everyone's got an opinion got you
in different mocks things of that nature
how much do you think knowing yourself
is a factor like
do you do you allow yourself to get
caught up like when people are
saying good things or negative things
does you know you're a human being
you're a young kid like is that hard is
that easy like when p uh let's go into
like real details there's in every
publication mock drafts there's
receivers that people think are gonna
get taken before you do you get
competitive about that how much does
self-awareness or just knowing yourself
factor into these this is one of the
biggest life moments that a professional
athlete will have which is the scrutiny
of them going into a draft how do you
think about that
i mean i definitely you know like you
said read it a lot and i really don't
take too much into consideration because
a lot of those guys have never played
the game they're just watching it and
just kind of basing off what other
people say but
i know my abilities and i know what i
can do so when i read stuff that
you know that doesn't add up to my place
that i'm like well he's wrong so he's
definitely not credible he really
doesn't know what he's talking about but
so that's why i just you know say to
myself and if i have questions you know
i ask my peers or
like alan or brandon and stuff like that
but like i said i know i'm very
comfortable with what i did on the field
and i know what i can do in the nfl at
the next level
interesting
do you feel like are you a player that
feeds off the crowd in any shape or form
or is it just all quiet cheering and
booing it's all the same it's not really
affecting you one way or the other yeah
it doesn't really affect me uh one way
or another you know that's kind of how i
grew up well i was always taught to just
you know block out the noise whether
it's the praise or the uh the booze and
stuff like that so that's just how i
live my life you know i take it one day
at a time and just try to stay even
killed
how about for you like do you do does
cheering or booing motivate you in
either direction or you also kind of
like you can't hear it honestly i
actually kind of enjoy the booze
you know that's always like a fun thing
you know even from college like when you
first you like being on the road yeah
when you first come out the tunnel
you know when you're here yeah because
it's one of those things where it's like
to me it's like have you ever been in
the stadium
and you hear like an incompletion at
home on third down versus on the road
you know on the road you know it's a
little bit different you know i feel
like even everybody's aura it shakes
back a little quicker because again it's
like
you know like i mean if you like again
have it through and out the away team is
is cheering if you away yeah you know at
home it's kind of like a oh it's like
you know i'm saying the errors being
taken out of the stadium but on the road
you don't get that you know on the road
it's a little bit different you know
meaning disappointment from the home
crowd
is more of a negative
kind of energy than than the cheering
because that's expected right of course
the opposing fans are pumped you're
three and out but at home it's like a
woe is me energy yeah yeah us jet bands
have that big yeah yeah right now
seriously like this we go three and out
our stadium we've got nothing we're so
pissed and so on tilt for the last 40
years and then at home sometimes should
you go a couple three and a half now
you're getting booed oh
especially if the media hyped you the
week before like a big game or this is
gonna be [ __ ] up or this and that
first drive
and that's the thing
you can ask i don't know how many
players ask somebody how many times
they've been booed away
you know you know if you're getting
booed away you're either scoring
touchdowns or coming out the tunnel one
or two yeah
right one or two who was who was the
toughest crowd you played in in college
like the loudest craziest you remember
anything yeah i hate to say it but it
was definitely penn state
it was uh my freshman year it was a
homecoming and i was
right you're a kid out of high school
fifth game fourth game in college right
like fourth game of the season i just
came off of being freshman uh freshman
of the week so i had high expectations
going into that game and
it didn't end i wanted it uh that
defense it had like five or six nfl
players that michael parson on there so
you know he was in the backfield
wreaking havoc and every time they get a
sack you hear like a roar like real life
yeah real loud like on the uh on a sound
system so like i'm in the middle running
my route and you just hear that roar
like you can't even get the full depth
you're out so and then the fans are
crazy so i definitely have to say that
was
the most loudest they did a whiteout or
a blackout that they had there
they just don't think it was all right
yeah it was white should i do like a
blue out or something i'll do something
else oh we do the stripe every every
blue moon i mean you guys just always do
you guys do a lot of color coordinating
i just white sometimes stripe oh do you
do multiple white outs per year pretty
simple i think sometimes depending on
the game yeah if it's if it's like game
day or if it's like a rival game we'll
do we'll do a couple white houses aj
that is one thing i miss about rex ryan
he brought a little bit of the college
atmosphere to us he was like it's a
white out he would make videos
remember that phone call that was sent
to all jet fans
college atmosphere is absolutely crazy
all right alan talk to us you're a ram
now i'm excited very very excited you've
you've i mean let's just call it what it
is i don't want bear fans or jag fans to
get upset with me but like you've had
most of your career on teams that
weren't coming into the season predicted
to go to the super bowl
is that like a new feeling altogether uh
a little bit um i would say for me i try
to you know i try to keep that kind of a
little bit not out of sight because it's
it's there and it's inevitable and i'm
actually happy to be a part of that you
know you're excited about having
expectations yeah yeah and i tell
everybody you know if
if you don't want expectations that mean
you're not doing something right yeah
you know like i mean having expectation
comes with good teams comes with good
players comes with people doing good
things it's it's inevitable you know if
if you're as a person trying to duck
expectation then you're in the wrong
you're in the wrong business of of uh
whatever you're doing because it's going
to be there so having that you know to
me just you know just it just makes you
lock in a little bit different you know
each and every day you know you you know
what you're there for you know you know
what time it is and just again being
able to join that atmosphere and that
team you know it's it's exciting you
know it's a it's i look at teams and and
players as like a as like a partnership
and that's kind of how you
feel with good teams you know it's like
you know we're we're in this together
you know it's not you know about this
not about that you know you're in this
together and you win this to achieve one
ultimate goal
i have a fun idea i wanna i've been
thinking about this a lot i'm gonna test
it here right now i wanna give out some
roses i'm gonna ask you guys some
questions
i think that we as a society have gotten
really good at like
like tearing people down societally like
we're just on it you know everyone's
just trying to [ __ ]
cancel and destroy everyone so i'm like
right so i'm like [ __ ] i'm gonna
start trying to do more like
giving out roses while people are alive
and all this stuff so let's go through i
got a series of questions i got a couple
already popping in mind for all three of
you let's start with you brandon okay
roses which player
you thought was gonna be fine not bad
fine solid could be decent
but you know growing up in this business
if i asked you which two or three
players one player
not that you were wrong about it but
you're like that's gonna be a solid
player but is like on the way to being a
hall of famer or as a beast like let's
give some roses out in the last five to
seven to eight years you're in the game
you're analyzing before they get into
league who are you like oh that's gonna
be a good ball player who right now is
[ __ ] putting in work
uh miles garrett is the first one all
right let's talk that's good let's talk
about that because that's a that was he
was gonna be the number one pick people
were super gassed on him to your point
i'm now going in my brain i'm he's been
better than i thought too even though i
thought he was like because he's so good
yeah yeah he's like for he's a freak i
just didn't think he was worthy of a
number one overall pick yeah and usually
i'm not i don't get
into the geek like teams do about why
like little things as to why a player
isn't good but sometimes
yeah and if i'm not repping the guy you
know what i mean it makes it a lot
easier to kind of do it so i got i was
getting into some debates with my
brothers and we're talking and i'm
focused on how weird he runs and stuff
and uh does that matter just right away
he came into the league i know it was a
beast and i'm like okay i was wrong i
was wrong
yeah yeah right away i did that with
patrick mahomes i was like i don't know
about that like like about for his
second game like yeah let me get off
this train right now i was super wrong i
don't want to talk about that anymore he
does everything though he's like he
even though he does kind of get him
like he should i mean he should get more
he should be up there in the discussions
with aaron donald in my opinion as far
as a game record you know he's that he's
so crazy but like i'm with you yeah yeah
yeah and he's a complete player he is
everything
um he's a good ball player let me think
other guys that just deserve some give
another thought i'm gonna bounce around
yeah yeah yeah what coach
do you think
you want to give roses to that has the
biggest impact for you to be in this
position right now as a player that is
going into the league if i asked you
that question yeah so it had to be my
little league coach uh carl pernell
carpool carl pernell yeah brunel yeah so
he he's kind of stepping to that father
figure for me you know my grandfather
was there uh
first grade so probably six
yeah so i used to spend a night over his
his house on friday night uh and he'll
take me to the games in the morning or i
stay home but just being around him to
see how you know he took care of his son
i'm like okay this is how you know i
know i had my grandfather too but seeing
somebody else outside the family do that
and seeing how he took care of his
family he took care of his son like okay
that's something i want to be like when
i get older so i definitely that's
definitely something i have to get the
roses to i love that
allen
let's give roses in a way that's a
little bit harder to but it will be fun
who do you think because i think you're
listen this was long i'll say it again
long before we had the luxury of teaming
up with brandon and repping you i've
just always like been a big fan of your
game i really i'm really genuinely
curious about what your season's going
to look like this year given the
circumstances because i'm also a big
stafford guy
which giving roses which
defender
do you really think
you've been in the league
that you're like and he's a pain in the
ass like he's really he's really a good
ball player three three come to mind uh
for me
uh actually four go ahead jason verret
uh is a dude
playing against him man was uh
we had some battles we had some battles
in jacksonville yeah uh stefan gilmore
he's a gilmore size man he has he has
everything he has the size he has the
strength he has the speed he played he
plays very very technical like each and
every snap he's gonna play his technique
um jalen ramsey you know he's a person
who's super athletically gifted you know
and he kind of plays a little bit
different in other corners but he's kind
of evolved and created his own kind of
technique and which you know already
from jacksonville when they drive no we
played we played uh two years ago
beautiful players reunited yeah played
two years together and then uh the last
was the person who i play against he's
retired now but it's uh revis
yeah he's a dude who man he he matched
me in 2015
every snap um he gave me a different
look each and every snap and it was the
first time in my career i actually felt
like i was
i was like confused yeah like like
thinking at the line of scrimmage you
know i mean i still had a pretty good
game but it was uh it was one of those
times where i kind of after that game
kind of readjusted my approach to like
the line of scrimmage and and the
pre-snap and how i kind of wanted to go
about my pre-snap playing that's even
kind of talking to him after the game
you know he he kind of just kind of you
know gave me some tidbits as to how i
should kind of approach the line of
scrimmage yeah so
that's interesting you know
obviously he's one of the best players i
got to watch every snap of
i really think about him a lot because
the nfl has gotten so much harder for
the defender
i still don't think there's been a
corner since him and there was guys
before him but since him i don't think
there's been another darrell rivas in
the league and jalen's amazing and
there's been other guys but like
he was
those two years 2009 10
were so crazy
like so crazy people
aj
that was a two-year span where if
somebody caught a pass
we were upset and surprised a pass and
i'm talking about the best receivers in
the league would come to new york
megatron and have two two and 17 one and
nine it was out of con
ocho cinco in his prime like
back-to-back games like blank
you know weirdness
it was super weird he got we crazy
i got my other one
mike evans
that's a great one i i'm with you on
that too i agree with that too i mean
i just think if you just hate texas a
that's what it m like yeah that's what
it seems like
i didn't hate mike at all coming i
didn't hate either of these players yeah
i actually liked mike i didn't think it
was gonna be crazy i mean you know mike
evans never had a season and that he
didn't catch for a thousand he's a beast
you talk about flowers it's just like
man it's hard to catch for a thousand
yards in a league i agree to do it every
year in your career that's that's uh and
we don't even really talk about him
amongst like the greats i agree i think
he deserves his and then another guy who
i did like too
but i think he should be talked about a
lot more is aj green as well i chose i
took two receivers but you know aj he's
a guy who was it his first seven years
in the league he went to a officer
he was first ballot pro ball
i agree that's a great julio kind of
outshined him a little bit for whatever
reason yeah i've always liked aj a
little more to be honest you know it's
really funny you bring that up i think
there's a lot of players through the
years who are like sensational
and just because of circumstances
you know like listen i think alan to be
honest like i'm excited that he's on
like this is like like alan
i think his career is going down the
path of where i'm about to go which is
there are players who
are grossly all-time underrated because
of pure circumstances no doubt and i
think in a person like mike evans
situation
i think that the football world and just
in general people get super infatuated
with like spikes and peaks
you know what i'm saying so mike kind of
being consistent around 700 1200 1300
1200 he may not have ever had a 17 1800
yard season but he's been so good and so
consistent to whereas like it gets
overlooked you know because people kind
of want that want that spike you know of
the i think of the 18 touchdowns or 1800
yards you know what i'm saying exactly
or 140 catches you know it's like
let's talk about the draft a little bit
so dbell's going through this big moment
we're only a couple weeks away alan what
about your experience let's get some fun
stories that maybe people don't know
yeah i actually i left my draft party uh
for a little bit uh i was
i was yeah i was frustrated oh you
thought you were gonna go first round i
i didn't i thought it was a chance i
could go first round i think i wasn't
upset with that i think it was uh for me
it was upset uh once again i got down to
the second round i think i ended up
being an eleventh receiver taking you
know and seeing a lot of people come off
the board uh in front of me you know it
was just frustrating that ninth and
tenth guy pissed you off
real talk before that you know i mean
but you know it was wonderful matt at
the fourth and fifth guy you were on
[ __ ] tilt when you eat the knife the
tenth guy yeah for sure and i mean
that's the thing i i probably left my
draft party
around like pick
40 45.
so i probably was like outside kicking
it for like 15 16 picks
you know just like chilling and i
remember my one of my high school
coaches had texted me like you good i'm
out i was straight i just i didn't want
to i was i was frustrated at that point
i didn't want to really you know be
around anybody
so
remind me what you know because again
and i love you david for saying i read
it i like like people like people are
humans
remind me because i don't remember
did people have you projected in the
first round or you felt you were
projected second round um i felt like i
was projected second it's funny because
like you know how you get your draft you
can like submit these games in like uh
like a form or something and like the
nfl kind of gets back to you where you
were projected to be drafted and i did
that but i didn't look at that until
after the draft so interesting yeah so
and they had me uh project that second
round
but
during that whole moment you talking
about when he was at the draft i wasn't
talking to him at all at that time um
we had a lot of players in that draft we
were just i was at home with my dad
watching it um
which i have another story about the
draft later but it's funny because
i remember his experience i was without
sean jeffrey for his draft experience i
was actually up close and personal with
him
very similar um
and i think he could be in store for
something similar as well
guys that they know i know and anybody
who really knows them knows that they're
gonna you know pro bowl level kind of
players
and it's just something about watching
guys get drafted by the way it's the
weirdest position for me in the nfl
currently yeah i was yelling at my tv
screen as a fan long before i knew as
much as i know today and i knew a lot
because i watched so much but
now i'm at a different place because i'm
under the hood
yelling for the jets to take keenan
allen yelling in the first round and i
think he went third round and the and
these guys all fit this i the receiver
thing is weird the league still yeah
over values in my opinion i and i'm
putting this on wax because i want to be
historically correct i think the league
slightly continues to over emphasize
speed at the combine for receivers when
the film is telling you a completely
other story and it just feels like
there's an obnoxious amount of second
and third round receivers who ball the
[ __ ] out that have the same narrative
i'll tell you significantly not slightly
it's significant like that's the
conversation that i've had most with
teams over the last three months
and i'm not trying to sell them because
i know you can't sell them anyway it's
more so like you said have it on wax
like when are y'all gonna wake up and
just look just look at the top receivers
in the game and go are those tracks 40
speed kind of guys or those you know
guys that you just cut on the tape and
they separate themselves you know i made
that mistake everybody continuously
makes it but one second the one thing
that is going to maybe change that
i was talking to a former gm a couple
weeks ago
is the teams that are switching to gps
instead of and so they can actually see
how fast the guys get up to in a game
like cooper cup or him for example as
opposed to looking at a track race and
seeing how a guy runs in a 40.
so i think is starting to catch up yes
like the next 15 years we could see a
change there i think it's two things one
i think
the over emphasis that well not the over
but the under uh emphasis is that when
you take guys that are more skillful
guys
when you get in the league especially at
the receiver position it comes to being
able to adapt your game
the receiver position i think is very
similar to kind of like a basketball
player it's like if you have all these
different things on your tool belt as a
player you can continue to adapt your
game over time
you're not just a speed guy you know you
can do a little bit of everything you
can continue to evolve your game change
your game maybe it's route running
whatever it may be you know you have all
these skills to be able to win
firstly and secondly i think the other
thing
the speed factor is a huge factor
for guys who don't have that dude under
center
to me in my opinion
if you go look at
the players who play with uh aaron
rodgers or uh
um
josh allen or any of the top
quarterbacks in the league and the guys
that they've had like even like you said
like keenan allen
and philip rivers you know what i'm
saying even with uh with justin herbert
he's had a ton of success but nobody's
nobody's afraid to guy who had great
circumstance imagine he announced here
phillip rivers and and that's but again
and i think he's more so i think he's
i don't think he's the beneficiary i
think the i don't want to say the
quarterbacks are our beneficiary it's
the combo but it's the it's the combo
and when i say it's the combos like if
you have a guy like philip rivers you
know keenan allen being keenan allen
he's going to have success
you know you don't have to worry about
can phillip rivers get king and alan the
ball in these different spots you know
as long as king is keenan he's going to
kill as long as devonta adams is devonte
adams he's going to kill we have the
person that can get him the ball at any
position on the field the whole like
conversation of like run [ __ ] routes
really caught my attention like forget
about all these drills on instagram like
you you big believer in that
is that the real
obviously you got to have some drills
and stuff to kind of like emphasize you
know other physical traits as far as
that you're training but definitely the
biggest thing is being able to run to be
able to run a route like if you're doing
uh stop routes at three yards and fight
everybody can stop at three to five
yards of course but can you stop at 18
you know how how fast can you get out of
your speed cut at 20 yards on the 20
yard dagger you know but you got to be
able to build that speed up for 20 and
then cut you can't just run five yards
in this because everybody could do that
you know that means it's basketball
basketball what you said there that's
huge like you see guys that were like
like david who he was a really good
basketball player so was alan well i
don't think he could have been in the
league allen really thinks he can
that receiver position really you know
you're kind of to get open you're doing
the same thing it's kind of like like
james harden made he probably would have
been a good wide receiver but not the
fastest wide receiver but again
um why don't you drop anything
i think uh seriously my man
catch everything for real and that's the
number one job you know again uh
is did you get better at it like how did
you get better at it like obviously like
people like some people have good
hand-eye coordination like even me and
aj are good at catching because we have
good hand but like how do you get like
from elite to super elite like when i
say that to you i'm saying that as a
compliment on purpose like you really
[ __ ] don't drop [ __ ] i i've always
been pretty good at catching the ball
that's fine i just started playing
receiver to my junior high school
so cause you were going to the nba
well i was i was smaller so i was like 5
8 you know early on so i played running
back but i just always kind of i guess
naturally been able to catch the ball i
mean i work i work at catching the ball
too for sure but i think my main focus
is always you know when the ball is in
the air is to catch it you know i think
i'm not really truly you know now i'm
kind of you know again uh adapting you
know to just be able to get catching on
opportunity so being able to you know
kind of put my body in the position to
run you know when i when i when i do
catch it and in better positions you
know but when the ball is in the air you
know the
the number one job is to catch it d bell
are you thinking about like you're in a
funny spot now most people when they get
out of school
they're kind of in control like dustin
decided he's willing to cut like they're
willing to come to new york like you
don't get to decide
like you're about to live somewhere
out of like a heartbeat you're gonna get
a phone call
you know five minutes later we're gonna
get a phone call and be pumped for you
and you might be thinking like man i
i'm about to live in this city like are
you thinking about that a lot or not
really yeah most definitely uh my whole
life i've been in indiana uh went to
high school indianapolis and then purdue
west lafayette's about an hour and 15
minutes away so it's definitely going to
be so are you praying that the colts
take you
i'm praying just to get drafted yeah
i don't believe you
i don't i'm not really crazy
yeah for sure i was just talking to my
mom about it maybe a few days ago like
but it's gonna be your first time if the
coach don't draft it at you outside the
city so
you know hopefully i can build the same
fan base that i built in indianapolis
and indiana to wherever wherever i go
alan when you went back to roses let's
go into another place
what player
when you entered the league most big
brothered you that helped you the most
anybody stand out
and maybe even if they didn't really put
their arm around you and say hey
youngster i'm going to be there for you
maybe somebody if you didn't have that
circumstance because something like that
doesn't happen
was there anybody on jacksonville that
you no different than what dd bell said
about coach was there somebody in the
locker room and you're like i like the
way that guy moves i'm going to be that
kind of pro when i get older yeah so off
the top of my head a few guys um
actually we had a super young team when
i got to jacksonville right so um it was
me marquis lee allen hearn storm johnson
brandon linder we all came in on offense
together
you know our first win that year we
started eight rookies you know but we
did have some vests like cecil shorts uh
mercedes-lewis um uh jack mcclendon
who's actually the player engagement guy
in los angeles right now as well that's
cool you know he's a dude who who for
sure took me under his wing but as i
kind of advanced a little bit it was a
lot of vets and retired guys you know
like i'm pretty cool with calvin johnson
steve smith um uh randy moss you know i
got i got some of the legend yeah so the
guys you looked up to yeah for sure you
know did you seek them out did some of
them seek you out was it serendipitous
or were you at like a event and you saw
them and you're like let me start to
build this relationship how did that go
down a little bit of both actually um i
i forget how i actually end up uh
getting super cool with uh with uh moss
but i ended up training in charlotte
with him for uh four to six weeks that
must have been cool it was super dope
you know being able to and even now you
know guy who came into the league and
did work
eight seconds in everyone was like we
[ __ ] up eight seconds this is the
crazy thing about it
he scored a touchdown in every single
one of his college games
you talking about moss
pennington was nice but come on
yeah yeah
he god that must have been really fun
for you yeah who was your favorite
receiver as a kid moss so that was it
huh yeah yeah right it was dope and
again um
who
who's your favorite receiver like in the
last seven eight years like let's say
because you transitioned to a big
program like purdue it kind of changed a
little bit but what about in high school
if i said to you
in your four years of high school who
was your favorite nfl receiver did you
have one yeah i liked andre johnson um
yeah he was a guy out like the light
talk about flowers that dude deserves
yeah i like andre yeah
yeah he was he was super underrated
that's it that's another guy
that's another that's another darrell
rivas roses bro we other than the fact
that stevie was on the other side gave
him a little bit of work but interesting
moss
andre was a beast yeah he was
real nice let's talk about basketball
playoffs are about to come you're always
talking basketball
um now that i knew that you could be an
nba player too yeah for sure brandon you
you you sneakily think you're phenomenal
in basketball i knew i wasn't going to
nba though um
what do we think like what's our hot
take
before we started this you're like i'm
not sure phoenix can do it i don't think
i was kind of saying i think maybe
they're they're the fact that they got
so far last year like sometimes that
second year
you know i'm also hot on the nets you
were talking about that off camera
before we started if i said right now
nba finals champion let's go around the
uh it's super hard but it's fun
i'll go let's play i'll go last second
to last all right
i'll go first i'll go first i actually
am pretty locked into this and been
locked and i do a show with draftkings
called props and drops and two months
ago i locked this in so i'm gonna run it
all the way through i i just mentioned
them i think it's gonna be nets phoenix
i'm sticking with it i've been on it for
months and i think it's gonna play out
um the nets are gonna have a tougher
road i think than phoenix i think
phoenix is gonna get themselves back
there um
and if i had to pick a winner
i think if the nets get there then
they'll win it so i'm going to go with
the nets
dbell
i got to go go to state
coming out the west yep and the east
east
east is tough it is
tough east is tough you can really be
okay with a lot of decisions i
personally say the celtics i get it yeah
i got and then us
and in that finals
i got the celtics taking it you got the
celtics getting out you feel they're
that hot right now yeah i got it i get
it i get it
i didn't
um
well my bias can't i have to pick the
warriors coming out the west i can't not
pick them
why
just because i think step
uh i just really like the warriors
um i think stuff i got i got to know
what that joke is i just think no i just
think steph's uh not only the most
underrated player but maybe a top three
player of all time but that's another
discussion um
and he says top three now i've actually
heard top top three and not two or three
but that's that's that's that's why he's
talking about part of you i live with
women that's why there's a part of that
i see where you go that was that joke
that was that joke hey thank you for
tearing that up so let's see it up
there's a part of you in your body that
debates with yourself and you know it's
not something that's accepted by society
yeah that you might think
in your mind and that's the best player
of all time yeah yeah that's profound
yeah that's a
i mean you know what's crazy i
definitely changed it things could get
very weird if like this was my whole
thesis and could by the way continues to
be with lebron like if you told me
lebron gets two rings in the next three
seasons that registers in my head as
like oh it got put together in la or
brawny came in and he went somewhere
else and it got put together like steph
can still win three four titles
when you talk about accomplishments and
titles and that sort of stuff that's
when i kind of back away from those
arguments why just because
there's so many like you give me the
side i can argue it right like i'm just
saying flat out pound for pound like if
i'm a coach and i'm coaching against the
team and you said who is one player
that i wouldn't want on the other team
in terms of having to account for him
all over it
for me so that's why i think steph but
anyway i would say warriors and then
it's a coin flip between uh boston or um
milwaukee and new jersey for me okay or
brooklyn yep but i'm uh i'm gonna go i'm
gonna rock out with the nets and
warriors man and who's gonna win it
warriors okay
alan yes coming out the east uh because
i'm a big especially once again the
playoff time
i'm big on
who has the best player
yeah i think that's what makes series so
tough you know so i think in the east
i gotta go with milwaukee order nets
and then in the west
in the west i have to go phoenix
man
phoenix or golden state only thing that
kind of makes me
with golden state is steph being a
little dinged up going into the playoffs
you know not kind of having i don't want
to say not having that rhythm but i do
think it's tough when you're playing
against a team like phoenix who has who
has been very cohesive in this happening
because i think they lost 16 games i
think that's nothing
18. that's insane yeah that is good 64
wins like i think people are sleeping on
them a little bit like i think it's
gonna be a rematch from last year i just
don't see it you do yeah i know you
really just don't i can't wait to text
you guys
and the reason why i say that man is
because phoenix has a complete team
they're pretty everybody knows their
roles they have a very cohesive team and
once you get to the playoffs
you know what's funny they remind me of
young golden state before they super
teamed out with durant like it was so
teemy like clay steph and draymond and
everybody surrounding them and andre
like as a vet like in that chris paul's
like a little bit more like they're just
teaming up to me and milwaukee has that
that's why
that's why i say to somebody exactly
the celtics play defense you know what
it is they play defense you know what
honest is a little more alpha than tatum
just a little bit and i love them too
that's my problem with the celtics those
two the two-headed monster and that's
obviously more tatum than brown but like
i don't trust it it gets cold out of
nowhere for no reason or logic i think
that like
the person i most fear on that team from
like real life like is smart smart 100
that player mark is smart
would be my favorite player of all time
if he was on the knicks that's how much
i love the 83 intangibles i sent i hate
going to nick's
celtic games because marcus smart does
12 things in a game that i admire the
most yeah but he's a celtic so i hate
him what are some of those things like
pulling on someone's shorts poking
someone in the ribs
playing deep like all these weird ass
things that like like like like
not patrick beverly like 15 percent a
little bit more not crazy about the last
you did you like
patrick listen i'm someone who has no
talent that has to rely on all those
things to compete and i because of that
i know how much it matters people are
not mentally strong and people are not
mentally strong out there you've got 88
of league
players out there not as mentally strong
as people think and little [ __ ] can [ __ ]
them up like a little [ __ ] i really
obviously that's like hyperbole but like
i believe in those little [ __ ] diving
like doing something with the crowd like
humans back to brands the way we started
this podcast brandon was just talking
about intuition
energy's real humans play that way like
little [ __ ] things like one
the player on your i'll give you a great
action i'll give you a great marcus
smart thing
i've watched you know the league the nba
is so about streaks right it's so
streaky 12 and over on it you know like
down 20 you win by 25 like it's very
streaky with the three ball and the way
the league is now i've seen marcus smart
multiple times just against the knicks
in the last two seasons
do the small little thing that starts
the 12-0 run
like you could just see the rest of his
team getting more hyped yeah
it's real you know who else has that
who milwaukee withdrew holiday i love
jewellery
by the way that's why
i feel like in the playoffs
because you have middleton who can kind
of be a possible with all due respect
roller coaster of some games when i say
roller coasters
to 17. you know what i'm saying like
it's kind of that range but we're having
giannis
and drew holiday and knowing what you're
going to get
the whole [ __ ] podcast
picking up our acoustics
and having
giannis and drew
in a seven game series
let's talk about other interests what
about fighting
here's what i mean by that
mma boxing or actual wrestling like wwe
stuff like any of those things ever hit
your radar like i love all those things
did you like that growing up
i'll let them start oh i grew up
watching like wwe go ahead so who's your
favorite wrestler of all time probably
rey mysterio
rey mysterio yeah you love the [ __ ]
flying around yeah we used to jump off
my auntie cows do the tricks and stuff
so
did you [ __ ] with the mask yeah most
definitely so i we we definitely uh grew
up watching that in the house we
couldn't watch it in my house but we go
around the corner
i love it we can go watch that for sure
you're a wrestling guy at all i was
growing up mine was neither uh the rock
or john cena
yeah you're that era yeah yeah
i was rocking sting
sting from wc now of course he was beast
he was him i did bang with the
undertaker too i'm not gonna lie the
whole wolf pack was aj who's your
favorite wrestler of all time
you kid
aj
aj what are you what up i'm 40 you're 30
35.
35 is a weird one it's the worst era
yeah because aj aj's like childhood was
in between hogan ultimate warrior macho
man my era and and the rock stone cold
he still got that because he was young
but the true childhood where it's like
this he had like tatanka and like
[ __ ] like duke the dumpster drozy and
all sorts of like weird that was the
bret heart yokozuna where the top top
top but it was like that wasn't the two
big eras but who is your favorite
wrestler actually i actually don't think
i know actually push comes to show
for fun try
the reason i guessed it was the british
bulldog is the british bulldog was a
good guy he turned bad and aj cried
because he was hitting like me
though all right hold on was it wcw or
wwe i actually that's who i thought it
was it was a wwe wrestler i loved that
like the monday night awards like nwo
yeah yeah
i was gonna say
um i was gonna get sean michaels
wow
was it wow okay okay crazy very
as a group
yeah greatest match of all time
ramon he came into the league earlier
when they would hype guys before they
one of the things that wwe did when it
was wwf that i thought was better than
anything was building up hype they would
they would do these promos for weeks
before the guys showed up in the ring
you'd be watching saturday morning and
mr perfect is the one that everybody
knows they did mr perfect for two months
before he went into the ring
i don't know if he was hurt i don't know
if he was still under contract kurt
henning i don't know what it was i don't
actually know the real details of why
but it was months that you'd watch
saturday morning because that's when
wrestling was popping in the 80s you'd
watch in the morning saturday morning
when when they used to have the best
guys fight like no names like barry
horowitz and k9 they used to fight like
scrubs they didn't fight each other like
it is now they like they would build up
guys
they hyped mr perfect by the time mr
perfect fought his first match he was
the second most popular wrestler in the
vince mcmahon did that
brilliantly for me it's macho man randy
savage by country mile because i'm also
i'm like this is why i was smiling when
you were talking earlier
i would have loved to be a professional
athlete singularly to be on the road
i want everyone booing against me i love
it it's i it gives me the smirk it gives
me my energy i love it i love it and
when i was a kid everybody loved hulk
hogan
and and macho man was a bad guy and i
was like i'm about macho man then he
became a good guy and then he got
popular and he won the title that was my
dude
no love for goldberg huh goldberg was a
beast that's beer that spear was nuts he
has a crazy winstream you were a little
more wcw
well because you said because me and him
are similar age
there was a little like yeah
and then the rock brought wwe back i
better say that because like when i was
coming it was like wc www wcw i don't
even know what station it came on but it
was kind of like
but it was a time where wwe kind of went
through something and it did become a
little bit more popular yeah the wcw it
was like
nitro they took all the guy it was huge
that's what it was
like
yeah right what about what about not
fake fighting
boxing any of the three of you grow up
loving it boxing for sure what was your
number one guys
i mean well
heavyweight was probably tyson how old
were you when tyson was fighting you
guys missed by seven yeah i just
remember it so i don't know i was
probably like 12. i knew i watched mike
tyson fights like before he even was the
champion of the world like coming up on
abc and like on espn
it was the greatest
when mike tyson beat trevor berbick for
the title when i was 11 it was like he
was a superhero it was such a big deal
how old was tyson at the time 18. yeah
because he was doing this 19 like
2018 he was the youngest heavyweight
ship in the world i'll never forget that
fight for as long as because burbick
also like the way he bobbled around the
ring it was crazy
um
yeah man mike tyson 85 86 87 88 mike
tyson was the cree he was so famous and
so popular you can't even imagine think
of like kardashian drake like like it
was different back then there was no
internet it was he was just yeah he was
michael jordan and michael jackson yeah
and by the way tyson was more popular
than michael jordan and it wasn't even
they weren't even in the same
conversation michael jackson was like
his name was mike tyson
in 1986 compared to
it wasn't even close mike tyson was the
heavyweight champion of the world
michael jordan was called a ball hog
that would never win a title
oh you're saying
at that time not overall overall it's
not even close the other way but at the
time 86-87
that was when jordan was considered
he'll never win like you guys are all
youngsters in in junior high
there was the big debate that he'll
never win a title this seems like
laughable now but he'll never win a
title because he just wants to score
because he couldn't get through detroit
detroit was [ __ ] the bad boys were
[ __ ] rough right tyson for you
two so like when i was younger um like
elementary school i probably said roy
jones yeah he was unbelievable
aj you you were i remember my whole life
i wanted you to be into boxing but it
was a i was working too it was hard but
remember roy jones when he got upset
like that
very good bro i remember that was the
one time i thought that you would get
into boxing i'm so well
i know that which is the best that was
been the best part of us being in mma
that you love it now like being up at
one o'clock and be like you see that's
yeah roy jones was the guy roy jones and
then like once i he was swaggy as [ __ ]
yeah and i like college and then into my
first part of the league
i probably would say deontay wilder
yeah that's like i came with i saw a
couple of deontay wilder here like early
beyonce where you were like who's this
guy's crazy yeah yeah yeah when he was
first kind of coming up
anything floyd that's that's the only
thing we really watched
i'm too young no but it's not too young
he's one of the greatest fighters of all
year for sure
i was a huge pernell winner my answer is
tyson and pernell whitaker and pernell
whitaker was like floyd 1.0 all defense
crazy he didn't have his floyd developed
some power later in his career but and
and i and is better than purnell but
pernell whitaker was the guy he was the
best fighter in the olympic 84 team do
you remember sugar ray was that your
error you know no i'm too young for that
i'm curious how he and floyd really kind
of compare
you know what sugar ray and floyd have
that purnell i don't think had
they were considered pretty they both
pretty boy they were considered defense
but they were nasty
yeah but i i remember when i started to
turn on my opinion on floyd because i
love purnell so much so i never wanted
another one and i saw him coming up the
game and i was like this guy's [ __ ]
good and i knew his uncle because i
remember his uncle fighting uh floyd and
uh his dad but i remember his uncle a
little more and
he got nasty in a couple fights and i'm
like cause sugar ray
everyone always thinks of like he was
smart he was a businessman he was
coca-cola he was trying to make that
money and in the 70s it's tough being a
black man now 70s he was really cheesing
it he was smart as [ __ ] he got white
america to fall in love with him
but he was nasty
that tommy hearns fight like i'm very
nerdy about boxing shout out to tommy
hearns and tommy hearns junior
guys man yeah am i went to middle school
with tommy harris jr bro tommy hearns
was one of my favorite fighters he was
so crazy good but you see it in that
first fight where hearns had him they
were both coming up the game
the hitman had him and sugar ray got
like me like he had he he's nastier than
people think and i respect that's a
compliment all right mma do you get into
that at all or no i personally do now
yes i saw my first fight the first time
i saw a fight because i don't really
like fights like that i don't want to
see a lot of gore but
you can't help but to appreciate yeah
they're doing i mean it's are you
getting appreciated respect a little bit
yeah i mean like mainstream fight i
can't like call too many people by name
but like definitely yeah for sure like
if it's like a mainstream fight like i
watched the whole card what do you value
you started yeah i watched it a little
bit uh i used to like uh silva yeah
anderson was crazy yeah i used to ride
with him you love mma
you're hardcore
not hardcore but i saw your reaction i
always see you mike you gotta
the next big ufc fight at the garden
we'll go we'll do some vaynersports
stuff yeah those guys are those just
different animals you got to respect you
know fighting is like all of it all the
even wrestling
wrestlers
wwf i still call it that
are all three of them boxers mma
thank god for mma because i think people
are looking at it a little bit
differently and definitely wwf wrestlers
there's so much more talent and skill
that goes into that than the general
public like people
boxing's nickname is the sweet science
like people think again i keep saying
thank god because i think people
understand how technically incredible
the mma fighters are and all the
different martial arts and jitsu and
wrestling and it's fun to watch i mean i
watched the first ufc
like when it was wild like crazy if you
ever watch the documentary like we were
in high school we're like what the [ __ ]
is this like
big dude and like they were like
different they didn't even have weight
classes so you'd have like a it was a
street fighter it was like some big
samoan dude and like an 80 pound guy you
were like it was a circus show
and we were like blown away by i
remember thinking they'll never i
remember the first one and i was like
this will never they'll never have a
second one this is gonna be banned
because it was like illegal and you
didn't know it was illegal forever
bloodsport it was
my backyard
what's up my man kind of like backyard
because even like when you think about
it like a lot of kimbo slices yeah
but i think that's kind of i don't want
to say what changed mma but even we look
at the background of a lot of mma
fighters
that's kind of like where they kind of
initially come from it's just kind of
like street fighting kind of but like
they're i mean their skill so then they
start kind of training
yeah when i say when i say like street
fighter i mean like maybe like middle
school like this dude could fight like
now he's training you know what i'm
saying jiu jitsu and wrestling are so
dominant court like like you're looking
at it like
it's not kimbo like like you know boxers
like big punchers you have them but like
yeah the talent is absurd like when i
watch it now i loved boxing for like
understanding how a jab set things up
defense like when i learned like they're
just kind of grazing the glove it was
just i was fascinated by it but mma
takes that to a whole other level
because you've got so many variances of
different styles and fights and
just some of the [ __ ] these guys got
obviously vaynersports had a big weekend
with al james sterling beating yon and
most of the mma world didn't see that
win coming and i felt so good for him
because he really did his work and i was
watching
i love reading people's
twitter and then looking at them being a
hypocrite like like like i see when
people cancel brands and then a year
later like have the brand in their photo
and i'm always like laughing at them
that happened with the algae main stuff
all these people were mad that al
jamaine out wrestled him like boring
because they were mad because they
wanted yon to win meanwhile literally 45
tweets earlier they're like yelling at
somebody about like who says it's not a
good sport and like do you know how
technical it is to wrestle someone to
the ground like it's amazing how that
one of my favorite things about sports
is emotion and i think that i mean it's
just at the height there's some what i
love about mma and this whole genre of
boxing like it's the first sports
like you go back to like like there's
something primal about two men
squaring off it's just it's the most
human thing so um
mano imano you know no excuses and no
excuses
and you can't take a break from those
sports and like like there is no break
there is no play off there is no you
know what i'm saying one-on-one sports
101 sports versus team sports have
fascinating dynamics and that's
something i never did as a kid that for
me you know having a daughter and you
know i'm saying having more kids i want
all my kids to play at least one
individual sport interesting i never got
a chance to play an individual sport
i play all team sports you know a team
sport can be frustrating pickleball have
you heard about pickleball i've never
heard of that okay pickleball is
exploding
seriously it's a mix between tennis and
ping pong is the best way i would
describe it you have to google it i just
bought a team in major league pickleball
because i played it four years ago and
i've been watching the data same way i
put not predict same way i observe tick
tock or nfts or all this stuff
pickleball is about to pop off
you should play it
is it fun to play that's why it's
popping off it's fun can you describe it
a little bit yeah the paddle is like
padded the ball is like a wiffle ball
type thing so what it's doing and the
quartz smaller and it's got rules where
it's what it's done is it's mitigated
athleticism
and power
to a place where people can really
compete each like
a 62 year old woman after you you you
play for six months ah smasher you'd be
stunned
no no i'm serious no i'm serious that
probably comma
comma that's what's
sweeping the nation people there the
sport was designed in a way that's
really now its popularity
is getting going and so you have better
athletes
racket hand eye coming in and you're
starting to see a little more of the
separation but here's a fun fact
consistently in big pickleball
tournaments the top games you have women
beating men yeah i saw you about the
team yeah
well i'm gonna buy a bunch of teams
including an nfl one eventually jets
let's speak about that dbell i really
need you to be a jet you know this right
like this is like my greatest dream you
gotta talk to brandon
i wish brandon listen
good news if if agents had anything to
do with it it'd be a wrap i would i'd
take the jets from office into hostage
land to get this done i haven't been
this hot about it
this is something i'm hot on even before
i knew we'd be lucky enough to represent
you aj i'm on the jets d-bell train i
know
um
the last time i was this crazy was shawn
green who was a running back from iowa
who actually then got drafted by the
jets
um so i'm praying i'm really hopeful
brandon i was about to say that i don't
know he wanted to take him great you
know that'd be great i i i know he's
gonna ball wherever he goes so
all right party partying thoughts
brandon what did we not we didn't get
too deep in nft land no we didn't um
party thoughts about what gee anything
brother just to wrap up the podcast
we didn't touch on anything you're
excited about anything any theme that
you took away
maybe something like oh gee i really
like that you bring up that roses thing
i'm gonna start doing more of that i did
i really do like it isn't it cool yeah
and i thought you'd like it well just
because i hate cancer culture and i hate
like the whole idea of judging people
off like one yes event or something like
that
so i do like that maybe that you need to
start a movement for real i really want
to i've been really hot on it so i
unveiled it a little bit here i'm like
we just need to start bringing energy
like literally like do you know how nice
it's gonna feel for some of the
i mean for that coach
you i mean this show gets listened to a
lot of people somebody's gonna know that
your coach and is gonna send him this
clip you know how nice that's gonna feel
yeah you know some of the players that
like d-rock just keep it it feels nice
you know
a brown sending this clip of miles like
it just feels nice
humans are humans getting complimented
getting roses feels nice no matter how
many [ __ ] roses you have it's still
nice it really does it's really just
nice yeah [ __ ]
my little brother got married this past
weekend congrats so i saw appreciate i
saw a lot of people from back home
and i had like multiple people kind of
come up and give me some roses and it
really did feel good nice and it wasn't
the fact of like you want the cloud or i
want to put it on instagram it was just
like man you know especially with
somebody you know yeah right yeah or
like in in brandon's analogy or ebell's
like like when two people live it like
coach lived it with him coach probably
remembers
noticing six-year-old d bell
taking note of him doing something
fatherly and probably thought a little
something like you know like there up
remus might hear this clip and be like i
remember talking like i'm i'm very
passionate about when the two humans are
the only two people that know the
situation there's something special and
that's what happened to you yeah the
people from back home
like you guys both know it's not about
the press it's not writing a mock draft
or an article or sending a nice tweet
like you two actually know yeah and
that's the thing too you know in
in the nature of the world now for
anybody who's kind of
higher profile to any kind of degree or
significance is always the opposite you
know what i'm saying there's always so
much heavy scrutiny you know so for a
lot of guys you know being able to give
people their flowers you know when you
can you know to any degree you know i
definitely think it's worth it for sure
after games
how to actually this is a great way to
end it and with a little story time
after a game
whether you win lose you're pumped or
very disappointed are you one to just go
back to the locker room and you know get
showered up and think or do you kind of
go chop up with somebody that you came
up with camps with or you know like you
used to play with because once you're in
the league things of that nature how do
you guys both play it consistently the
same way different every game depending
how do you play a d-ball like after your
game is in college well mine was pretty
much consistently uh no matter like
winner loss you know i'll stay after
sign autographs and then shoot back with
my family my family waiting in my
apartment for me and we'll chop it up
about what happened with the win or what
happened with the loss what about
opposing opposing players is what i'm
more interested in opposing players
as far as would you talk to them after
game exchange jerseys
talk to the guy that lined up against
you went to high school with some kid
like you knew you went to high school
with dude and he's on the other side go
seek him out and say what's up after
game yeah win or loss yeah i'll
definitely stay out there and uh you
know give them their respect say good
game so yeah parker i ain't going about
what yeah
like i don't aj we i don't see us we i
don't think we would have been great at
that i feel like if the loss mattered to
me and i was upset depends on the game
that's what i think i would play off
game
playoff game i'm
losing a playoff game i'm not even
talking to another human being let alone
an opposing player i had a couple of
close friends do that before and like i
never forget it so i would never be that
way like that's not right that's all i
got a homie that didn't even shake my
hand after a game
that's real roses though that's not bad
that's roses in mind and this is still
my guy that's my guy monty simmons okay
monty simmons if you're listening email
me you're my friend now we're friends
we're family monsters that's my favorite
family now i [ __ ] with that [ __ ] you
brandon we lost i'm out i'll talk to you
in a week and we can chop it up and be
best friends but this exact second after
i lost this [ __ ] important game [ __ ]
you your family your future family
everything [ __ ] everybody i hear you i
hear you hey you hear what he said
alan you're you you could get like that
a little bit once you're out yeah it
depends on the game yeah for sure like
for me what was the game that you were
most heated about in your professional
career of jacksonville chicago
most heated leaving like like actually
you know do you have one
yeah it's good
because it's fun for jags and babies
first one that come to mind is week one
2016 we lost to green bay in
jacksonville
i remember when i played i was playing
for jacksonville i remember that that
was there at that game yeah that one
what happened they kept their own
passing appearance against jacksonville
no he was getting he was getting held
and pied the whole game that you
couldn't get a flag for nothing yeah i
ended up getting maybe one but we lost
we lost by maybe like four but it came
down to the wire like like the last
final player just wanted it yeah we lost
and then um see i respect that one lost
super salt this is why i [ __ ] with alan
week one loss yeah that's the way it
should be chicago
probably saints 2020.
saints 2020
yeah yeah
that's yeah i actually got the rock a
little more so
boys thanks for being on
appreciation
[Music]